and to my hero that's who I chase now
when I was 15 years old I had a very
important person my life come to me and
say who's your hero and I said I'm not
going to think about that give me a
couple of weeks I come back two weeks
later this person comes up and says
who's your hero I said I thought about
it you know who it is I said it's me in
10 years
so I turned 25 10 years later that same
person comes to me and goes so are you a
hero and I was like not even close
no no no she said why I said because my
heroes me at 35. so you see every day
every week every month and every year of
my life my Hero's always 10 years away
I'm never going to be my hero I'm not
going to have pain that I know I'm not
and that's just fine with me because
that keeps me with somebody to keep on
chasing
so to any of us whatever those things
are whatever it is we look up to
whatever it is we look forward to and
whoever it is we're chasing to that I
say Amen to that I say all right all
right all right
you guys hey just keep living huh thank
you